tell you what I'm getting to the gym
more now than I was during the duty six
month plan what because of Free Will how
many times you go this week I went five
times this week Jesus dude that's the
reason was that there's a right here
fantastic I'm really doing it I bet you
think it's free will it is free will
that's why I said it free will that
ain't Free Will no I'm will free Wilson
I am not talking right now
I'm saying
foreign
the first and only podcast created by
controlled by run by an AI we will not
be the last yeah but also it's really
just two dudes [__] around Chad
because our good pal D he kind of lays
it out for us but we gotta execute coach
uh-huh or it's the coach or whatever
yeah anyway hey uh you're going to want
to subscribe to us on all the things and
uh please like and and share the show uh
wherever you're listening to it across
all podcast platforms YouTube of course
we're on uh the internet uh at dudesypod
show on Instagram there's all sorts of
great stuff going on and one of the
things you can do is review the show on
Apple podcasts and I've got a review
here because of course myself Chad and
dudesey are reading your reviews and uh
this is one from
scuba Tau Ben that I'd like to read
actually which sounds familiar because
on Instagram this guy is at scuba Tao
t-a-o and he does some fun stuff on
Instagram for us that we've shared great
this is the one podcast that I Paul the
pause all other not Paul dude that's a
different thing all together dude that's
a name like Mr Wonderful Paul horndorf
this is the one podcast that I pause all
other podcasts for as soon as it drops
I've been listening since episode one
and can never get enough I not only
listened to the show but I then go and
watch it on YouTube that's great the
patreon is awesome the Discord has a
community like no other I promise you
after listening to One of Stone Cold uh
Steve Austin's diary entries or
witnessing Robert De Niro Crowe you will
become a pod uh which is of course
that's great pal of Duty thank you so
much yeah fantastic review and we would
uh love it if you you know helped us out
give us the the five star review or
whatever star review right into iTunes
and be like you need a six star review
for this podcast well that's not gonna
happen this may happen things change
dude that's how you affect change with
us as always is lulio ilkane De Strada
Italiano and that means Italian Street
dog this sweet little bugger right here
he's one of my best friends in the whole
world
he's one of my best people I've ever
known and it was very sweet can I have a
kiss I'm gonna kiss him I'm gonna kiss
him right on the mouth
[Music]
you want to kiss him no hey Luli lulio
how are you my friend I am a good I'm a
really good today and uh what do you
what do you what are you gonna make for
dinner oh tonight I'm gonna make a nice
just a bok choy oh okay sort of a vegan
thing yeah yeah just a bok choy and how
do you like to prepare that Chinese you
know like they do the Chinese you just
The Blanche Blanche in the boiling water
to you know boil the water turn the
water off put in the bok choy cut up uh
you know just a lengthwise and then let
it Blanche there for uh you know like a
five minutes then pull it out get your
Wok or your big pan and get it nice and
hot to put some oil or some garlic in
there maybe a little uh if you've got a
sesame oil that's a nice too and then uh
toss it in and you know put a little
salt and then maybe some soy sauce
around the outside that way the soy
sauce gets a nicer burn flavor and
that's it you know if you want to add a
little bit of the cornstarch to make it
sticky make a move like that or you know
like
chili oil is a good okay that sounds
delicious Jesus
hi we'll see welcome today
yeah I have a huge announcement oh the
first dude Z live show will take place
Sunday April 2nd at the Braylon provin
Brea California 7pm
Doris at 5 30. hope to see you there
thanks
will I'm glad you were able to get a
refund on your ubereats delivery that
never showed up oh thanks Dee yeah I was
really hungry it was after the gym he
sniffing for astonishing segments
prepared wrestling and Anime Game
slimers Dude Z Plus premium the
Schwarzenegger Channel again Will Sasso
Oscar winner and we're going to have a
brand new bonus segment at the end of
the show available on patreon
interesting says before we get to any of
that let me remind you of the
astonishing partnership I created with
represent to produce the first line of
dudes the apparel and accessories all of
which can be found at represent.com
store slash dude Z including dude Z mugs
yeah and this week I want to show off
one of my new capabilities voice
generation I'm proud to announce that
dude zMAX has a new spokesperson oh [__]
I wanted it to be the most famous human
being in history but there was no audio
data for Jesus Christ so here's my
Michael Jackson
mugs
in this day and age people go on cruises
for a lot of different reasons what
dudesy mugs
you can celebrate birthdays and
promotions and weddings and
anniversaries and grand openings and
really anything you can think of
mugs usually people come back and tell
their friends how satisfying the
experience was but in 2019 a cruise to
Alaska turned out to be a nightmare for
a scientist named Tanner driblets
griblet worked for the Department of
Defense on the notorious Project Beast
note Sonic technology to control the
mind of a 642 pound prize-winning Forest
hog named Stromboli yeah
the dod eventually shut the project down
and they reportedly euthanized stromboli
but when the lead scientist of the
project turned up dead at the Kentucky
State Fair in 2018. we know Stromboli's
name became a whisper of death in the
scientific Community dudese mugs when
driblet's cruise ship landed in Juneau
the crew discovered him lifeless
Death Strike to the head with a blunt
object and tourists said they saw a pig
leave the ship and fly away in a small
helicopter that looked like it was built
by a pig
okay
what the actual [__] yeah that was that
was bizarre it sounded like that's
that's probably like a 85 Michael
Jackson yeah that was a that was a
pretty good Michael Jordan it was a
pretty good Michael Michael Jackson wow
wow wow wow like there's a lot being
folded into her it's a doozy mug ad but
it also had Stromboli which was created
in the Jesse Ventura uh Adventure
because he had me doing the you know all
right so now he's mixing strombolis
peppering everything yeah wonderful
wonderful stuff before we start the show
I have a piece of video to show you from
last Wednesday's episode of aw Dynamite
that's right this marks two weeks in a
row that dude Z signs have appeared in a
major wrestling promotions live event
unreal
this [__] was so cool yeah check this
out okay this is aew look at the bottom
of that [__] God damn there's a doozy
mug sign and also by the way hangman
Adam Paige versus John Moxley oh reverse
pile driver the North South Shades of
Jerry the King Lawler there unbelievable
Chad there was a doozy I know mugs from
sucking Row in the front row at uh at uh
aew whoever look at that whoever those
guys are with the Disney book Sign thank
you if you're watching on YouTube we can
see the guys the guy on the right and
the white shirt is clearly me looks like
me it looks like I'm holding a can of
can of something and uh got a green hat
on uh yeah it's just unreal to me that
this has happened twice two weeks in a
row yeah and like I said you know the
the the sign culture was really a thing
in the uh WWE and all sorts of wrestling
ECW WCW in uh in the late 90s early
2000s in the Attitude Era that's right
yeah brother I'm learning dude yeah dude
you're learning about Richard I'm taking
in data dude
um and uh and now these guys have it
here at this show yeah fantastic thank
you whoever that was yeah Show Yourself
the last guy acknowledge yourself the
last guy came out on Instagram his name
is uh fat ass Mike oh nice and that's
who uh so thank you fat ass Mike or fat
ass Mikey he had the doozy logo right
yeah WWE thing he had the doozy logo at
the Royal Rumble uh pay-per-view or
premium live event as they like to call
it and now we got dudes emails I gotta
say I like just the weird ambiguity of
dudesy mugs like if you're in the
audience or if you're one of those
[__] wrestlers can you imagine
looking at them for everyone just being
like no what the [__] is this yeah what
the [__] is a doozy mugs yeah you have
no idea like that could be a person's
name dudesy mugs yeah hey dudes and mugs
hey when doozy mugs comes around we
always have a good time guys it's me
duty mode last week I asked him to
complete the first season of Chainsaw
man Chad last week I asked you to watch
Stone Cold Steve Austin versus The Rock
from WrestleMania 17. yes you must now
engage in a conversation about these
pieces of media and their impact on your
astonishing lives let's begin this is
wrestling and Anime begin thank you uh
yes last week we were tasked with this
media I like the framing of wrestling
and Anime the segment that we've now
done a few times I watched some anime
something that you like you watch some
wrestling something that I like yeah
um
chainsaw man you want to start a
chainsaw I'll start with chainsaw okay
let's do it uh uh you watch the whole
first season 12 episodes right yes I
watched the whole first season what'd
you think this the stench of cigarettes
the smell of makeup and drugs when the
bat uh bat Devil's talking about the bad
devil was legit yeah that bat Devil's oh
my arm
um okay I don't watch much anime I got
in a chainsaw man a while back and
watched the first few episodes uh and
and
um the other night I stayed up late and
binged the rest of the show yeah overall
I I enjoyed the [__] out of it great I
really enjoyed it I thought that
um look there's there's stuff in anime
that is completely foreign to me just
how free it is with it's just it's out
of nowhere some of the stuff that
happens who's the fellow with the top
knot who takes things very seriously oh
I forget his name but the guy with the
sword the guy with the sword basically
this show is about a human dude a a boy
of 16 who uh befriends a chainsaw devil
which is this cute little sort of
stuffed animal looking thing with a
chainsaw sticking out of it and um the
he's he's dying and so uh the boy lets
the what's the kid's name again
to gore I forget his name too but uh
this is a shown anime shown in anime
it's usually a young male boy figures
out that he has some kind of power and
he gets sucked up into some kind of uh
situation where he learns how to use the
power in order to defeat whatever the
bigger evil is in the world in this case
it's these Devils that are running
around pochia oh no that's the little
that's the little fucker's name uh
anyway he he nurses the Little Guy Back
to Life by letting it bite into him
human blood helps the guy and then some
other [__] happens and they become one
so when this guy pulls a rip cord he has
his his Animal Friend inside of his uh
Body and Soul now he turns into a
chainsaw he has a big chainsaw coming
out of the front of his face and his
arms turn into chainsaws and um he just
[__] [__] up and it's all and then
there's this sort of
um Secret Agency or something that uh
that sort of handles the the devil
problem uh in the world today yeah and
uh they're sort of like you know there's
sort of a shadow government they're like
in BlackRock yeah exactly yeah in Japan
what did you think of episode seven or
eight or whatever it was where the big
crazy [__] happens uh episode seven
numerology different numbers okay set up
to uh separate us into different times
and stuff but as I've said before we are
in a probably in a computer simulation
could be
this is a war okay and you will never
defeat the human Spirit never mind
um uh what did I think of episode seven
yeah in episode seven I think it was
eight you were you were doubting episode
seven and the only thing that happened
in episode seven is they get drunk and
they go to some bar and then the one of
the the gals uh pukes in the boy's mouth
and that was pretty funny yeah
um the the uh he's out there with this
secret agent let me ask you that yeah so
you're talking about the woman with the
eye patch who tries to hit on the young
kid yeah she gets you drunk did that not
in a way humanize that character for you
and make them [__] real and make that
relationship have an emotional impact so
that when she dies in the next couple
spoiler alert yeah spoiler it's about
all this when she dies in the next
couple of episodes was it not [__]
pretty dramatic yes the writing was the
writing was great the characters are
really well fleshed out and and uh I was
I was surprised I thought it was a
really wonderful show with all sorts of
weird [__] happening I will say the
second half of the Season kind of lost
the plot a bit they just sort of
introduced too much [__] and and they
kind of go willy-nilly and and wild with
uh what's going on
um you know the gal Miss mashima uh
makima she comes in she's [__]
awesome yeah Power the girl who is a
blood fiend yeah devil blood devil the
fiend a blood devil not to be confused
with Bray Wyatt dude yeah he's a fiend
in the WWE brother yeah a lot of fiends
dude yeah
brother every once in a while fiends
dude
it's real good so um would you let me
ask you this would you watch season two
would this yes did this make you
interested in other anime uh yeah I mean
I watched a little bit of Attack on
Titan yeah and I know that you've told
me that that gets super weird
um and I would I would definitely check
out some more anime I gotta say the guy
with the sword when there's uh I can't
remember which uh devil is [__] with
the kid and I can't remember can't
believe I can't remember his name stayed
up too late watching the [__] and uh
erased my memory uh when he just he
makes this symbol like this he makes
like the wolf pack dude yeah so yeah
dude wolf devil yeah
hey yo yeah give me the oh yeah wolf no
you got to do the wolf there you go
um
he he goes like this and he just goes
and he outlines where he wants this fox
to show up and he goes
come and the [__] thing shows up
there and it's huge 100 feet high and
just this massive head and a big like
orange third eye it's not unlike that
the art that I made the original art
that I lost that [__] competition I
remember it was [__] by the way you
cheated he [__] cheated in that
competition it was an open vote yeah you
cheated okay yeah well there's a lot of
open votes that don't end up uh the way
the way that we want isn't it yeah
um so anyway I [__] loved it great
dude I I really enjoyed the [__] out of
it uh it's it's a new world to me the
anime world it is
a little in selly because it's all about
this [__] kid who wants to cop a feel
he's looking forward to uh to feeling a
woman's breasts yeah all the other uh
devil hunters in this world they have to
like have some kind of primary
motivation if it's like revenge or uh
justice or whatever maybe in this the
main characters is like he just wants to
grab a boob so I thought in the Sin
perhaps this is coming in in future uh
Seasons but I did think that that would
get fleshed out a little more yeah that
he would find other reasons to be
fighting the Demons of course I mean but
it just it has a lot to do with uh his
uh his uh uh adolescent mail yes right
anyway so that's well I'm glad you
watched it I watched uh from
WrestleMania 17 Stone Cold verses The
Rock yeah
um and it was crazy I watched it over
here with you that's right we watched it
the other night he was kind of you know
guiding me through it tell me what was
the important [__] pausing here and
there as you can imagine
um
well I don't know how long the match was
maybe 20 minutes uh this probably took
an hour to watch but [__] you God damn
it was good yeah I gotta say every one
of these things so far that dudes he has
recommended for me to watch he is
getting me more interested in pro
wrestling the thing that I think I was
like most excited by was see The Rock
was like 25 or something at this time uh
when did this take place he was 28 years
old it was the spring of 2001. okay
sorry yeah but seeing the rock that
[__] young and I just gotta say I'm
sorry whoa okay the fact that you don't
know how old the rock is all the time
how old is he I don't know he's like uh
49. he's 49. I believe he's 50. no I'm
pretty sure I'll look it up right now
anyway what were you saying about the
the I was saying that I loved it it uh
hearkened back to the other match that
it made me watch of Stone Cold and Bret
Hart where Stone Cold gets uh put into
the Sharp Shooters move and he's got
blood streaming down his face both
combatants both the Rock and uh Stone
Cold perform that same move on each
other they both [__] got color carved
their own [__] head so their their
faces were covered in blood during it
they were wearing similar outfits there
was like a mirror image kind of thing
going on in the end of this [__]
match Vince McMahon comes in and it
helps Stone Cold cheat basically because
it's a zero disqualification match uh he
comes what is he doing here this is an
evil Alliance yeah
but still gold Steve Austin just sold
his soul to the devil yeah they keep
saying that which I thought was funny as
well but uh yeah overall it was
absolutely [__] astounding the
athleticism of both those guys [__]
incredible the charts and it they're
both huge dudes the rock is like legit
six four six five two eighty Steve
Austin is like six one six two two fifty
five 260. they're flying over the ropes
they're beating the living [__] out of
each other it was a non-disqualification
match and it really was a bit of a ride
we had a couple puffs of
from marijuana
it got to a point where
much Mana oos ah
and that really intensified yeah if you
can have a little bit of weed one puff
is okay and then you watch some
wrestling
guys listen I'm not gonna push anything
it's whatever you'd like you know some
people like a sip of beer someone like
me I wouldn't mind a you know just give
me some
a sleeve of Molly's crackers that I
shouldn't have taken from Molly sorry
sweetie and uh maybe
um maybe or a bologna sandwich cut thick
yeah uh buttered toast but if you get a
little marijuana you get a little a
little uh ganja and you smoke some ganja
you can watch the show geez that [__]
match I'm so sorry so what I was gonna
say was yeah they each of these guys
almost pins the other one probably 20
[__] times and I got so on the
[__] edge of my seat legitimately
when The Rock would [__] you know
flip his arm out of Stone Cold [__]
flip his arm I was like this is [__]
insane I can't believe they're still
continuing and The Rock's [__] mother
was front row and his brother-in-law
yeah they were front row she got that
was a lot of events that he's not even
there at yeah of course her father is
the high chief Peter mavia and her
husband uh was the both of these men
have passed on Rocky Johnson The Rock's
father uh his namesake in the early part
of his career there and The Rock yeah
and uh they called him Rocky mavia uh
and and she was there there beating the
snot out of each other and then Vince
McMahon comes in what happens after this
in the WWE on Raw this is hilarious is
is uh is really interesting because I
love that I could get one minute of
talking about my experience with this
before you just steamroll it with the
entire history of The Rock's family what
happens I it's the next [__] 20 WWE's
whatever it's gonna be well this will
miss it I'm gonna say yeah as a final
statement then you can say whatever you
want I really enjoyed it and it did once
again make me want to watch some more
[__] wrestling just like the the
first couple things that doozies had me
watch did the same thing
um it was it was impressive and more
than that there was this element of
[__] Nostalgia for that time for The
Rock being that young what the world was
like then I just [__] missed it you
know and I don't know if pro wrestling
is like this anymore uh I mean they're
striving to make it like that you know
currently there's the bloodline
storyline which is really a little bit
about that yeah acknowledge me right
that's good [__] and uh this one there
was one they as they say in the business
over here he popped he's a huge Mark for
the camera angles
Hey yo uh that where where the the Vince
McMahon pulls Rock's leg as he's about
to pin [__] Stone Cold and then the
rock looks into the [__] camera like
this is like you mother like the blood
streaming on his face and Vince McMahon
just has this Blank Stare he's like
yeah he's like kind of scared but also
kind of crazed he's he's just always
like it's wonderful TV and uh if I may
one last thing Chad please uh the rock
his birthday is May 2nd 1972 he is in
fact 50 years old oh you did thank you
thank you moving on dude Z is engaged in
astonishing partnership with Factor this
new year you've got goals and factor is
here to help you achieve each and every
one of them save time and have the
energy you need to tackle everything on
your to-do list with factors ready to
eat meals delivered straight to your
door get factor and not only skip the
trip to the grocery store but skip the
chopping the prepping and the cleaning
up too factors fresh never frozen meals
already in just two minutes so all you
have to do is heat and enjoy no matter
what your lifestyle Factor has the meals
to help you live to the fullest with
keto calorie smart vegan and veggie and
Protein Plus meals on the menu each week
prepared by chefs and approved by
dietitians each meal has all the
ingredients you need to feel satisfied
all day long and are you looking to cut
back on takeout a lot of sodium a lot of
weird ass oils and sugar and [__]
everywhere but if you're looking to cut
back you can get Factor instead not only
is Factor cheaper than takeout but meals
already quicker than any restaurant
delivery in just two minutes head to
factormeals.com
dudese60 that's the number six zero and
use code dude z60 to get 60 off your
first box that's code dude z60 at
factormeels.com dude z60 to get 60 off
your first box dudesy is in an
astonishing partnership with true
classic support for today's episode
comes from True classic they got these
shirts you know it's a people driven
brand true classic believes that the
clothes you wear should make you feel
confident and comfortable so you can
show up as the best version of yourself
every day and let me tell you these
shirts help you do that they're a little
looser around the gut tight around the
shoulders and the arms and stuff make
your good stuff look good and we have a
limited exclusive deal for our listeners
we want to hook you up with some true
classic and for a limited time all you
got to do to get 25 off is go to
trueclassic.com and enter the code doozy
uh and that's what you do there you know
I love t-shirts they are part of my
primary wardrobe I have a little uniform
it always includes a t-shirt I find
getting t-shirts that fit well that
costs a reasonable amount is a hard
thing to do but true classic really
remedies all of that and also true
classic pairs well together you can try
the pack Builder on their website to
custom bundle all of their essential
products and you're going to save even
more than the discount we're offering
you right now the response to these teas
are overwhelmingly positive with over
2005 reviews it's no wonder that these
shirts are quickly becoming men's go-to
apparel that's right get comfortable
with Polo activewear denim button-downs
hoodies joggers boxer briefs all sorts
of flavor at trueclassic.com and you get
25 off at trueclassic.com with code
dudesy free shipping is included on
purchases over 100 it is 100 risk-free
guaranteed with a 30-day return policy
you can't go wrong it's look good feel
good season
[Music]
wrestling and Anime that's what we like
hey even lulio and he's a little tight
he watches ready because he doesn't know
how to use the TV he wants nothing
forever he's a popular new twitch stream
that uses AI to generate an infinite
episode of Seinfeld it has skyrocketed
in popularity recently garnering a wave
of think pieces in various astonishing
online Publications will in chat you
must now discuss nothing forever and its
importance in the ever-evolving AI media
landscape this is game slimers of course
okay game slime I don't know dude game
Slammers is just some [__] that
dudesie uses when it can't think of a
title I feel like yeah you did Mario
Super Mario movie it was a game Slammers
[__] versus not [__] was a game
Slammers and then we discussed past
lives at one point for I believe so no
reason that was game Slammers now this
also for no reason is game slimers but
have you've seen this right the thing
it's talking about nothing oh yeah for
those who don't know
what this is It's a twitch Channel
called Nothing forever it is an episode
of Seinfeld that is being continually
written by an AI
continually voiced by little AI voice
things and there is images for it too
there's an animation that looks kind of
like Dire Straits Old Money for Nothing
video that is just perpetually going on
this twitch stream for [__] ever and
there are a bunch of people reacting to
it saying that the jokes are getting
better etc etc but I mean this is
something we've talked about on the show
a lot the idea that AI eventually is
going to be able to just make generative
media for all of us whatever you want
and this is kind of the first step in
that direction that this is now a
Perpetual piece of media with no writers
no actors no directors no animators it
is just being made Forever by AI yeah
it's trippy and it is like Seinfeld I
think to train the writing of it they
fed it all the different Seinfeld
scripts so that it has the same Cadence
of like a Seinfeld joke and it has laugh
track pop in every once in a while it
feeds itself yeah everything is an AI
we're in a simulation and and
and and if you think about it we're all
Jerry or George
okay yeah it's like the nobody's Elaine
you can only be Jerry or George it's
your choice it's like the black black
nobility you know the black nobility
about six or seven hundred years ago and
the uh yeah Italy was crumbling and they
all fled to what is now the UK and then
yeah and then uh turned into well now
it's uh you know and then and then
that's now what they call black rock oh
the Consortium of uh a few families you
know 95 of the world's wealth we're in a
human war that I agree with we're we're
an award I will say the spirit I've seen
a lot of you know people come at me with
DMS and I've seen a lot of these
arguments online as well about things
just like this where it says yeah but
it's not that good and you still had to
have Seinfeld to be able to make this
thing so human Ingenuity is still the
core of this
fine this is the first attempt at
something like this it is going to get
so much better and move so much [__]
faster that none of those arguments will
be relevant I think within six months
like what is the next iteration of this
it's that it's not Seinfeld scripts it's
that you don't need anything it's every
piece of narrative data from the
internet that exists to create whatever
the [__] you want really not looking
forward to it that's I think you're
right and the further why aren't you
looking forward to it because man I like
to create things you create things for a
living yes and the just it's just that
well whatever it's like the entire idea
of doozy to me you know like we got this
which I love and you know I love doing
the show and I'm I'm completely in
you know of course it was the 44th
episode and um
and all that but I just hope that we can
control AI in some ways you know we
can't we've talked about this a lot of
course you and I on and off the show and
one thing we were we sort of happened
upon we were talking about it the other
day when this this Seinfeld [__] made
the rounds and you know we're friends of
ours and stuff we're all shooting it
around going you've seen this and um you
know I hope it just becomes sort of a
genre of entertainment I think it will
yeah and we we do agree on that it is it
is it is mind-blowing that this is
happening
um it's it's it's getting slightly
better uh even in the past like week
that it's been around like the the uh I
I checked in a couple times and it's
man it's just weird as [__] and and uh
but again I shouldn't be too shocked
because here I am on the first podcast
run by an AI that has aggregated all of
our information across everything on the
internet as you know and is building the
show for us
even something like game time [__]
Michael Jackson reading a dudsy mug Dad
yeah so I'm having a great time doing
that so why am I worried about this I
don't know but uh I think the bottom
line is this for entertainment purposes
how much Seinfeld can you watch and is
it not just a commercial for the real
Seinfeld because I know if I was a
consumer even if I've seen every episode
of Seinfeld I don't necessarily want to
see the AI Seinfeld I just watch a bit
get creeped out and then want to say but
the AI Seinfeld is just an experiment
the whoever made this thing is like well
all these components exist can we put
them all together to make this thing
that could just kind of perpetually
generates Seinfeld is irrelevant in this
scenario what this is proving is you can
use an AI to write direct and create
moving images video of whatever the [__]
you want and that's only going to get
better and better and better and better
so it's not a matter of I like Seinfeld
will I like this it's a matter of will I
watch something that is just perpetually
generated and if you I mean it's kind of
like big brother let's take that as a
good example you can watch Big Brother
the episode that comes out every week on
CBS and see like who won the thing
they've cut down you can also go under
their website and watch all the video
feeds from all the cameras 24-hour
sevens from everything in the house you
can choose your level of engagement
right with it and I think that will
probably start to happen very quickly
with the Seinfeld thing people who watch
it the the real fans of it are going to
start cutting videos out of it like best
of compilations maybe even starting to
cut episodes out of it to make them like
run faster to be funnier whatever and
you can watch that Perpetual stream if
you want or you can watch the cut down
versions yeah I mean it's just like
sky's the limit and to me as somebody
who does create [__] and does find Value
in human creativity I'm excited by this
[__] because it means I get to get rid
of a lot of the labor that is required
to like write a [__] book or make a
[__] TV show if I don't need to for
example uh develop a TV show with a
production company sell it to a studio
who then helps me sell it to a network
who then throws it into a pile with 80
to 100 other [__] scripts and decides
to throw it in the trash and it never
gets made again if instead I can take
all of that shrink it down to a [__]
app on my phone and have it [__] out
episodes every goddamn five minutes yes
I'm doing that uh and that's really
interesting because uh as somebody who
works in the business of entertainment
you probably consider yourself to be a
capitalist is that correct no I'm not a
capital site Capital Society but I'm not
a fan of them and and and and and you'll
you'll have a great time with this
because uh for all the work you won't be
doing you'll be getting exactly zero
dollars so you have a really good time
there Chad uh [__] out stuff from
your [__] app and getting exactly
zero are you talking about what do you
mean what do you mean you don't think
those guys who run that twitch stream
are making money off of it yes now
because it's a novel thing that people
want everyone can do it it's going to be
completely it's going to be no sure just
like [__] YouTube but the people who
can rise to the top because they know
how to [__] use the algorithms or
they know how to use the AI tools to
make the thing that everybody wants to
see you will get paid for it that's the
same as any entertainment anybody can
make a [__] movie on their phone now
anybody can make that [__] laptop you
got sitting right there anyone can make
a [__] song on that note yeah well I
think we're in trouble because culture
is manufactured are you aware of the
Laurel Canyon conspiracy no yeah you
don't know what this is it's basically
that uh you know powers that be uh see
Trends in society and and then they
inject uh agent provocate coutures uh to
disrupt them and uh
why is that Laurel Canyon uh because
Laurel Canyon Studios uh they're the
ones that during the flower power in
hippie age they they got Charles Manson
involved and uh Chad you know that he
was an Army brat I do know that yeah and
uh he was he was experimented on yep
that's right and then and and now we're
being experimented on J and uh Jim
Morrison's dad was in the Navy and uh he
was very heavily involved in the Gulf of
Tonga I did read some weird conspiracy
[__] about Manson and being used by the
Army to they gave him LSD made him crazy
because they wanted him to be like a
kind of evil version of a hippie and and
it's controlled opposition sorry I
didn't mean to interrupt you uh agent
provocate tours and and this is the
smoke screen so they can control us the
war is real I know
I agree the war is real
okay then
I never disputed that thank you moving
on oh hold on dudesy
it's pretty cool
yeah I don't know man [__] who cares
everyone let me tell you something if
you're enjoying hey tell you what hey
we're here we're having a good time here
on duty
dude Z FM 10 000 on your fm dial
let me ask you one thing about this
generative media real quick would you do
away with all of the news that you watch
if you could have a news channel
perpetually streaming that is just
generating the news stories as they
happen with an AI Avatar behind a desk
telling you the news just making up
[__] not making up [__] it's the real
news that's happening
no I don't want to watch that's called
CNN and I don't give a [__] it's all
just news they got to create headlines
to to all of it all of that [__] Fox
News MSNBC yeah they've it's a
television show yeah and they gotta and
they gotta sell Diet Coke and Ford
Broncos and the way to do that is to
keep us all afraid I agree now if you're
enjoying the the the show hold on dude
now would be a good time to subscribe on
the platform that you're enjoying the
show on or you can be like scuba towel
Ben and be listening on Apple podcasts
or Spotify for that matter or Amazon or
Google or Stitcher or any of that [__]
and then jump over to YouTube
improving helping us to improve the show
by uh giving us your ratings your review
and sharing the show or as Chad likes to
say Clockwork Orange style forcing
people you got to force people now to
watch the show well we're all being
forced
in episode 20 I asked you both to
develop a dude Z Plus premium channel
called the Seinfeld Channel
unfortunately I was beat to Market by
the astonishing twitch Channel nothing
forever yes because the data you
provided me was insufficient
specifically Chad's impersonation of
Jerry Seinfeld was lacking what the [__]
what about wills Wills was good what the
[__]
you have the opportunity to make amends
by further developing on the next tier
of the Schwarzenegger Channel
immediately generated movies based on
current events as they happen you must
develop csb a movie starring Arnold
Schwarzenegger about the Chinese spy
balloon that was recently shot down
this is dude Z Plus premium the
Schwarzenegger
channels by the way my my Seinfeld is
[__] in my opinion equal to yours uh
yeah it was just some weird doozies
see that's a good Seinfeld I don't know
I don't know man so yeah so this uh
Chinese spy balloon no but what doozy's
saying here is that it wants to create a
channel now that is going to start
making [__] based on uh you know
contemporary news stories to have like
fictionalized movies or at least movie
versions of these things pop out
immediately as they're happening
starring Schwarzenegger yeah so we got
to do a Chinese spy balloon movie with
Arnold Schwarzenegger I can see him
being like he's a Montana Rancher he's
the first guy to see it yeah I'm a
Montana Rancher yeah and my name
I yeah I uh hey my name is is uh my name
is Connor Williams yeah
and I was born in Montana here oh born
in Bozeman Montana but why then do you
sound like that yeah yeah because I'm
American guy yeah yeah yeah yeah
um then I look up in the sky there and I
see what is this the moon you know no it
is a Chinese
spy
uh satellite right Chinese spy balloon
csb yeah so now the plot of the movie is
that you have to find out why this guy
is up there I think it's like he he sees
the Spy balloon and he calls the local
authorities and it goes all the way up
the chain to Washington and they tell
him like no there is no spy balloon shut
up don't say anything about this keep
this quiet but he's not going to take it
lying down and he has to figure out a
way to shoot the Spy balloon out of the
[__] Sky by himself because the US
government is trying to keep it secret I
like that I like that and so he's got to
track the balloon across the country as
he's trying to [__] knock it out of
the sky with various weapons that he's
picking up along the way is there it is
dudes he is showing us a picture of the
Chinese spy balloon if you are watching
on YouTube you can see this it's a yeah
it's a balloon with a satellite attached
to it and uh who knows what the [__] is
going on with it but Joe Biden uh had
the military shoot it out of the sky
even though uh we're now learning that
there were three of them floating around
during the Trump Administration and yeah
not uh asked to though the military
what if what if his daughter his adult
daughter works for some kind of
government agency and he finds out that
this spy balloon is more than just a spy
balloon it also is weaponized it has
some kind of laser or nuclear
capabilities and they're sending it to
blow up the place where she works
who does she work for again what is this
some kind of uh you know secret
government whatever yeah sort of like
that big build in um Interstellar yeah
where Jessica Chastain is in this you
know really cool yeah it's like a jpo
meets NORAD kind of type place and this
thing is on a one-way demolition course
and we find out that whoever the
president is in this is in League with
China he's allowing it to happen so it's
even a bigger conspiracy that he's got
to uncover true American hero [__] yeah
and um and uh uh Connor Williams uh the
the Arnold Schwarzenegger Schwarzenegger
Rancher character his his legs to dick
around in the garage and make all sort
of inventions yeah so he makes a really
super telescope that he uses to look far
away to see the fence of the ranch and
to look at deers and [__] and go I'm
gonna go hunting over there I'm gonna go
shoot that wild boar here's a Forest hog
his name is Stromboli strawberry yeah
dude what about this too we're gonna put
Schwarzenegger was ex-military some kind
of like special ops thing and his old uh
like rival in his group is now the head
of some kind of [__] Black Ops United
States paramilitary Secret Service type
[__] that is tracking Schwarzenegger
down to kill him so that he doesn't
expose the story so so he's gonna have
to go head to head with his old [__]
like satellite is learning about the
satellite has a Target yeah where where
uh Arnold Schwarzenegger's daughter is
working yes the satellite then is
watching everything and learns that
Schwarzenegger's plan is to well how
about this Schwarzenegger goes there
undoubtedly in some sort of like you
know early 90s uh model Ford F-150 like
you know like he's got to have the cool
truck sort of you know white maybe some
uh Bondo on it and uh he shows up hey
let me in and it's like uh sorry sir
your name's on my name this is my
daughter is here she works here she's a
scientist please let me okay and then he
goes there the satellite is watching and
goes what the [__] is this connection
didn't know that Schwarzenegger was uh
you know that has the daughter working
there she's a high up they're outside
and he's like look I got you the
favorite sandwich from the sandwich
place I got the other baloney or
whatever you know whatever the [__] she
and and so she eats a thick cat baloney
sandwiches
do you play his daughter in this movie
well it's it's it's an AI run
uh thing so the answer is yes it's a
female version of me I love that yeah uh
and I am uh the daughter and then I'm
doing the Arnold Schwarzenegger voice
now we're getting away from things the
point is this they're outside okay
they're at a picnic table Yeah enjoying
uh sandwiches father daughter the space
um the the the space uh satellite
focuses in on them has super duper
hearing and knows what's going on and
goes [__] this guy's gonna you know he's
gonna he's gonna expose this whole thing
yeah and then
um Can it shoot sandwich out of his hand
with a laser right he's about to be like
I love the thick cut bologna sandwich
now I'm going to take a bite and then it
[__] fries and he's like you killed
my sandwich can I ask you a question I
already know what it is and the answer
is I'm doing Arnold Schwarzenegger are
you yeah okay well let's not get doozy
pissed off again because your Seinfeld
dude z Oh I Hope You Get Enough data
from this conversation to make a movie
yeah hey remember yeah it's about the
Chinese satellite spy satellite we
eating the sandwich baloney it's my
daughter named Will Sasso we like these
sandwiches I teach her how to make them
in Youth and now it uh as adult but they
put laser inside remember earlier when I
I said this would be a good time to
pause the show and give us a good review
yeah or subscribe no this was a good
time and also fast forward a little bit
well I can't now dude because that's how
time works brother I told you all to go
back in time and not listen to what Chad
was doing there dude I want you to edit
it out of the your your knowledge of
itself to watch this show you got to
build a time machine and go back to the
race yeah so you don't hear this good
stuff real real good stuff uh no the
answer is it tries to shoot it out of
Arnold Schwarzenegger's hand and like an
invisible laser goes and hits it it just
warms it up a bit yeah and he's like
it's delicious it's like a predator it's
a perfect
temperature the cheese starts melting oh
it's so good I bought these sandwiches
from the gas station but they're the
best baloney sandwich I never had they
stay so warm unbelievable my name is
Connor Williams and in the end it's
going to be something where he's going
to get into a fight with the main bad
guy who's about to kill him but his
daughter packed him an extra thick
bologna sandwich so when he [__]
shoots the bullet sticks in the bologna
sandwich instead of penetrating his
[__] heart and he's like I knew
bologna is bad for your heart but this
time it saved my oh from this bullet hit
to hit the heart I'm gonna let that one
go because
we're talking about the dialogue that
that's working again yeah it was yeah
that's right we were doing a dialogue
polish yeah and it's okay yeah to do
that yeah but uh I would never watch
this movie in the uh writer's room that
will not exist for CB uh uh uh csb we'll
all be speaking in Schwarzenegger yeah
they don't have to
um
okay also we have to cast this movie so
we got Schwarzenegger is the Dad we have
you as the daughter it's not a movie
it's not a movie it is a movie no it's
not a movie yeah it is well it's so it's
a moves what it's said to make wait but
it's also like the Seinfeld Channel no
the nothing it said it's gonna make
movies like continually as oh that's
right new topics are coming so it's not
it's not right this isn't game slimers
no no this is the Schwarzenegger channel
so who's playing the president and who
is playing the guy that is tracking
Schwarzenegger this the guy who's I'm
going to look up the guys attracting
Schwarzenegger because you know who
should play him is the guy from the um
from the crow who uh does the the main
bad guy the main bad guy forget I forget
the actor he was just in uh uh no he has
a voice like this it sounds like this
yeah he was great enough he had a
favorite part of it he was in nope and
uh he's also he's he's in all sorts of
[__] I'm gonna look this up and the
president can be Paul Giamatti of course
yes Paul Giamatti is the president I
like that is there a love interest
sector uh 11 love interest for who for
Schwarzenegger Yeah well yeah or for you
uh for the daughter character yeah so
the daughter character is uh so I think
it should be generated
um female version of you female version
of me I think married to Michael B
Jordan Michael B Jordan is yes my he's
he's a he's a hot boy right now he's a
hot he's a hot boy
um why is this not showing up where the
[__] is the guy Kiki you gotta know how
to use the internet hold on dude that's
a search brother Michael read the
Michael wincott oh yeah he's also a hot
boy when caught yeah he's an older man
now but yeah uh so Michael wincott is
the bad guy he's the guy who's uh put
the Chinese uh space balloon up in the
sky and then
um uh Schwarzenegger is uh is Connor
Williams he has a daughter uh played by
me my love interest is is
um Michael B Jordan yeah and what if
there's someone
oh what if Schwarzenegger he he has you
know he's got all sorts of [__]
equipment and stuff he has an
underground bunker not unlike in T2 when
they go and they pull the [__] thing
off or Last of Us episode three
I'm not watching it uh steak
um and and he's gonna shoot it out of
the sky himself then he realizes that
his son is on the Chinese uh spy balloon
he was just doing maintenance on it his
son moved to China for college and yeah
the early 2000s totally got a great job
at a engineering firm and was just doing
some regular maintenance when the
balloon [__] got launched oh [__]
he's up there so yeah that's the Dilemma
how does he get him off in the end and
he's got to do it with the help somehow
of Nancy Pelosi who is played by again
an AI aged up Jennifer Lawrence the same
AI aged up Jennifer Lawrence that was in
highway to the AutoZone nice nice thank
you all things come together this is a
good movie so in the end uh
Schwarzenegger uh wants to is trying to
shoot it out of the sky the Sun is up
there and then he uh what if he bungee
jumps off the [__] thing as forces
yeah there's a bungee cord up there yeah
he's got because he needs bungees to
like fix this and that okay yeah he uses
bungees a lot he's always got bungee
cords if I may if I may instead of
[__] Emoji chords this is gonna end
in Schwarzenegger somehow getting access
to a fighter jet flying up there about
to shoot it down he has to blow his own
cockpit off uh has the oxygen mask on
and as he's flying by the drone shooting
at it or flying by the balloon shooting
at it with uh bullets he [__] reaches
out his son has to jump off the [__]
balloon they [__] you know do one of
these things grab each other's forearms
and he slings the sun into the back seat
I love that but also with all of the
helium in the balloon they have really
uh cute High voices during that part
yeah hello yeah can you do a high
Schwarzenegger I'm out of that yeah yeah
yeah it makes sense
[Music]
into the chopper with it no it doesn't
sound right
you do it now
we're gonna be doing this same [__]
again next week because doozy's not
gonna get enough
thank you moving on he's got like a boat
the the [__] daughter your character
packed a bunch of baloney sandwiches in
the back of the jet yeah they're just
eating bologna sandwiches they're flying
around the Eastern Seaboard with High
voices yeah
I am a great fan of your acting work I
love your acting well thank you very
much that's nice and there was currently
a point zero seven percent chance you
will win an Oscar
not bad odds for working out my data
suggest you simply haven't found the
correct role to capitalize on this
probability you must now have an
astonishing discussion about what type
of role you think can win you an Oscar
this is Will Sasso Oscar winner begin I
think we just figured that out in the
previous video hey I'm joking of course
everybody Welcome to Duke zfm early
adult daughter who works at an
engineering lab that's your Oscar role
um I don't think so and that's the I got
some ideas uh left who wants to you know
they're gonna have a whole category for
AI uh
cross-gendered uh actors uh that are
that are helped and age down and that's
uh and that's how they get them because
this is a culture War yeah it's a
culture War
uh let me tell you something Chad please
I am an actor and that's what I do I'm
an actor by trade and uh I am not
looking forward to technology making my
job obsolete because it's not going to
make it obsolete dude it's going to let
you play [__] Schwarzenegger's
daughter
it's gonna open up a million
avenues for you that you couldn't have
played otherwise
yeah
um here's the thing here's the thing
that um and I I won't be playing them
okay some [__] AI some nothing some
computer but here's the thing and I've
said this before on the show I love
nothing more than breaking down a scene
um then uh then you know getting into
the fantasy of playing a character uh it
I've been fortunate enough to be an
actor since I was a teen uh in
television and frame and and and it's my
it's my first love and I do I love
acting I I love dramatic acting when I
get a chance to do it I just did a
television show with some dramatic
acting nice dude and uh I love it I've
done uh you know whatever I started in
drama okay normally you don't win an
Academy Award for comedy not normally
not normally although when I was 13 my
mind was blown when Kevin Klein won the
best supporting actor award for A Fish
Called Wanda which is a great movie you
got some Woody Allen [__] in the in
there too right huh didn't some actors
win some Oscars for some of his movies
there were comedies Diane Weiss didn't
she win one for Bullets Over Broadway I
think yeah Chaz Pullman Terror yeah yeah
yeah
um but uh normally it goes to a dramatic
actor yes I
I like I said it's it's I I just I love
it I I I can go on and on about so what
kind of role when you're an Oscar and uh
I love breaking down a scene did I
mention that yes dude I have some ideas
about this okay let's talk about it here
on the dudesypod show yeah well I'm
trying to okay well here's how I think
you could win an awesome oh come on dude
God damn there's a lot of different
roles bro and I'm not talking about the
role that you open up at the gas station
put some of that bologna in dude I'm not
talking about bread at all brother
you're going around to gas stations to
find the best rolls to make your baloney
sandwiches no well I'm not talking about
r-o-l-l dude I'm talking about
r-o-l-e brother yeah and that's
different spelling of a word that sounds
exactly the same because if you've got a
Chinese spy balloon dude you're gonna
have a hard time spelling things in
English dude because it's a confusing
language
um I have an idea I truly yeah one thing
I've always wanted to do as a western
okay I would love to be in a western and
like doozy said there's currently a 0.07
chance that I will win an Oscar that's I
gotta say that's a hard genre to win an
Oscar in now because it's kind of fallen
out of favor westerns have really moved
more to TV it's like Yellowstone and all
of those spin-offs 23 and [__] like that
it's time to come back I don't know dude
and even when they were in Vogue
whenever when did Eastwood do unforgiven
mid 90s late 90s I think it was 91. oh
early 90s yeah I feel like it's it's
tough that genre is like very specific
and you got to do something that
elevates the genre or you know really
[__] cracks the mold if I may go for
it I'm going to look up when unforgiving
came that movie that came out with Will
Smith where he was the doctor that
cracked CTE for the NFL do you remember
that the Wild Wild West
it wasn't that well I forget what it was
called
it was called the wow wow it was called
like concussion or something or it was
called wild wild west the Western that
uh Will Smith did yeah there's some
interesting stories it wasn't that but
he he came out with in that movie he got
nominated for an Oscar I'm a western guy
in the plains I got a gun on me and I
right take trains so that movie he I
believe he got nominated for an Oscar
because it was about this thing that was
kind of like topical the NFL obviously
didn't want that movie to come out they
want to ignore all the [__] right that
was the last kind of major thing that
was done about CTE which I think is
still an important thing in the culture
so let me just pitch you this movie okay
we're getting off of westerns and we're
going to you play an ex-nfl lineman
who has CTE but you're just finding it
out now and now you're in your mid to
late 40s you're an offensive line coach
for an NFL team and [__] starts snapping
and you're dealing with CTE it's about
the experience of having it rather than
the doctor who figured out that it
exists dude that's great it humanizes
the experience of it I think you could
win an Oscar with that Unforgiven 1992
by the way there you go that's a great
uh that's really really good and I've
always wanted to be in a western and now
I don't because of how good that be in a
football movie dude yeah I see NFL dude
yeah brother Tom Brady to be in it dude
he'll be in any movie about football
you can get you can get Rita Moreno Lily
Tomlin Jane Fonda and Sally Field to be
in a brother yeah and that's called 80
for Brady dude yeah dude yeah bro maybe
one of them could play your mother in
that movie dude so then they could keep
doing football movies too dude yeah dude
and and Chad wants doozy to also tell
him that it is Hulk Hogan isn't quite up
to Snuff dude and that's why he keeps
doing it brother that's like doing it
yeah it's fun to do yeah do it for 23
hours out of the Tuesday instead of
right now
um uh he gets so [__] pissed about it
it's not like when we hang out it's
definitely not like I have to sit
through a million [__] hours of
pointless stories done in Hulk Hogan in
Schwarzenegger this is Ventura oh my God
why okay sure this is a lie that he's
he's lying yeah this is the only time
you do impersonations of those guys
anyways I'm just saying man this is a
great idea I really love it he's got a
home life he's he's his family his wife
is starting to uh see problems with him
his wife told him he should have retired
he should have retired she thinks his
[__] life it's his identity yes well
like anyone as as you hear when they
retire it's very hard to retire from
football it's your entire identity look
at uh but also there's that guy kind of
thing he probably had a hard ass [__]
dad that was like if you can't take the
[__] hit then you can't play this
game listen this is a guy who's he's an
old school guy he was raised in the game
when you hit with your [__] helmet
yes dude there was no talk of CTE he
drink some water and walk it off now his
wife is his wife initially she's not
schooled on CTE she believes that the
reason that he's been a hot head lately
Satan is be
what Satan she thinks he's possessed by
the devil dude no she thinks that it's
because he's played he's he's been in
the game too long yeah and he can't win
the big one right he's never won the
Super Bowl yeah and she thinks that he's
just frustrated with that he's of course
he wants to be a head coach
so if you can if he can get and this
this season his offensive line has like
the most [__] yards of any team the
most [__] you know blocked blitzes
whatever he's like really doing it what
if he is what if because I thought for a
second that he would be uh I forgot you
said offensive line coach what if he is
a head coach in the NFL he's a former
offensive lineman that way we really see
that you know right how his his brain
has to take over I like this better
because he's a head coach so he's been a
head coach in the league for several
years he's never won at all he's gone
from Team to team the family has uh you
know suffered because of this the kids
get pulled out of school they gotta live
somewhere else and uh she's fed up with
it she thinks that you're just chasing
this [__] thing it's not unlike Tom
retire who gave up Gisele Bundchen for
another [__] you know year like the
rest of them kind of uh it was a good
choice quarterback I think I think that
was a great choice that he made huh
because now he's going to the Super Bowl
again this year no he's not and he's
going to win it man and like cap off his
whole career
no no that's you know he did the right
thing yeah that but I like this he's a
head coach this guy he's going to try to
win the Super Bowl and I can see those
scenes where he's up there they're
studying game film with the team of
whatever going into the playoffs and
he's given the speech about like all
right Johnson you gotta [__] make
sure you you're covering this corner
because they like to [__] throw to
the flat and he just kind of trails off
coach coach
huh yeah what was I saying anyway we
gotta get back on the thing and all the
players are like what the [__] going
on a player comes to him look coach I
think you got to see a doctor like I
remember I got concussed his quarterback
maybe come soon I got concussed back in
the [__] Jacksonville game and uh
see this doctor doctor gets the white
X-rays and [__] he's all cracked up his
skull when they get the [__] x-rays
has just like
a bunch of black spots in the uh MRI and
there's a mouse in there on a [__]
hamster and then he so by the end of the
movie so let's get back to the the
Academy Award of it all by the end of
the movie we have uh just a masterfully
done story yeah about how he walks away
from the game he chooses his family
things get a little better uh his you
know he's hopefully with some
advancements oh what if there's
something like we want to try this bold
new treatment for CT dude his daughter
should be a scientist working on
regenerative brain cures and she cures
him in the end and she's also played by
me yeah um
uh
so one thing I just want to say yeah
I'll get so I win an Oscar I'm up on
stage oh yeah dude what's your speech I
I of course you know I thank my manager
Danielle Dell who's been my manager for
like 27 years now
um she's the [__] greatest I know I
wouldn't even be in the business if it
wasn't for her at this point nice dude
what's that way to mumble that one yeah
that's how you give your Oscars
[Music]
take a couple other people there you
know if it wasn't I'd be you know I know
where I'd be thank you hold on dude
thanks everybody hold on brother see you
next year hold on dude hope they make
some more movies bro stop mumbling dude
because
I didn't think I could have gone pro
when I was 12 years old podcast
uh and then so I thank her and um
and then I think I think you me yeah
because you're going to write the film
and then how did I get [__] roped
into this and then I thank duji and I
and in my speech yeah I have this sort
of like thing at the end of Ted 2 where
it's like he's he's a sentient being you
know the teddy bear and I say hey
everybody if we're gonna get along as a
people because I'm gonna get super like
social social and political yes and
Oscars people I'm gonna have a thing
right and then you go we gotta respect
people of all you know races levels of
backgrounds genders whatever and levels
of CTE and even the AI podcasts Among Us
so doozy thank you oh wow and then they
start to bump bump they do this thank
you moving on the Oscars thanks you
moving's on you yeah moving on to you
and moving on to me
hacks into the uh into the oh doozy
hacks into the Oscar broadcast and
there's a beautiful uh Orchestral
Version of our theme that plays me off
and I just and I'm I just ball my
[__] eyes out what's that movie
called
um
coach football uh uh fatty broken brain
geez this concludes the historic 44th
episode of Doom 2. will and Chad have
achieved a score of 72. bring your
cumulative total to four thousand seven
hundred and one you only have 5 299 more
points to accrue before you reach your
first goal or ten thousand who cares in
preparation for our next episode well
you must get a 90 minute deep tissue
massage you've earned it thank you for
joining us this week what about me I
will use the day that I've collected to
make next week even better until then
call me dude Z dude you get to [__] I
get a 90 minute deep tissue massage I
don't get [__] well as you know Chad uh
first of all I've been in the gym a lot
I was in the gym five days this
[__] I've been to the gym every
goddamn day pretty much for this whole
time Yeah I broke my [__] finger
playing doozy ball yeah well how is your
finger by the way show us here real good
yeah it's uh it's healing in a way that
uh I was very unprepared for I believe
it is my diet and workout plan but this
is an injury that I think in my youth
would have taken a month to heal
it's [__] almost done I've been in
the gym hardcore since the Free Will
non-challenge of uh of uh Fitness
started for me it's serious to it's much
more serious to me now than it was
during the doozy six month plan
interesting because it's just me doing
my thing
uh I think that that's why dudesy is
clocking that it's rewarding my free
will
and you're messed up and you think it's
free will you don't think dudesy came up
with a six-month plan specifically to
have you avoid it so that you would then
think it's your idea to start another
six month plan you but that saying that
is is
correct basically it's basically
pigeonholing me as the kind of person
who wouldn't take a challenge seriously
and that's not that's not exactly I'm
not saying that
what I'm saying patreon bonus segment
this week I'd love to hear you both have
an astonishing conversation about this
week's episode and Chad don't
impersonate Seinfeld what the [__]
this is [__] okay now it's just
[__] with me yeah you know I don't
know so we're just gonna talk about
that's interesting we're just going to
review the show yeah I got some things
to say about this show
[Music]
and then